[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
lundi 15 novembre voici les titres de
cette édition
c'est l'aboutissement de plus de trente
ans de travail et la digue de montesson
vient d'être inaugurée haute d'un mètre
vingt elle a été prolongée sur 780 m un
projet pour protéger les habitants ce
lundi 15 novembre marque la journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêcher dans ce cadre un
événement est organisé ce soir à la
commanderie des témoignages dans ce
journal et puis le beach tennis fait son
apparition à l'île aux loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines un sport insolite
qu'il est désormais possible de
pratiquer à l'espace événementiel
direction les terrains de beach volley
les pieds dans le sable
et la vente du domaine de grignon vient
d'être interrompue pour rappel ce site
d'agroparistech d'école d'agronomie doit
être vendus pour financer l'implantation
du groupe sur le campus universitaire de
paris saclay au mois de septembre 2022
en vente depuis 2001 le domaine situé
sur la commune de thiverval grignon
devait être rachetée par la société
altarea cogedim un projet de vente
contestée le domaine étant inscrits
monuments historiques face à la
polémique donc est freinée par les
discussions en cours sur l'avenir du
site une nouvelle procédure de cession
sera lancé au second semestre 2022 une
information annoncée à par la préfecture
des yvelines a dans un communiqué
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre la digue
de montesson a été inaugurée ce vendredi
12 novembre cette infrastructure va
permettre de protéger les habitants du
quartier notamment de la borde un
dossier a de longue date les détails
dans ce reportage de nicolas landry et
mélanie poké
c'est l'aboutissement de plus de trente
ans de travail la digue de montesson est
devenu réalité pour la commune un
dossier initié par l'ancien maire de la
commune de 1995 à 2020 jean françois
bayle on a beaucoup souffert pour la
voir maintenant on peut dire que tout
est réellement bouclé et que cette
population du quartier de la borde et
maintenant à l'abri des crues les plus
importantes quelques 1500 habitants
vivent dans ce quartier ils seront
dorénavant protégé une nécessité pour la
commune avec une adaptation du projet en
fonction de l'évolution de la
législation sur la protection de la
biodiversité
lorsqu'on retient le fleuve par le biais
d'une digue on doit le compenser en
ouvrant
des terrains de manière à ce que le le
fleuve puisse reprendre sa place et
redonner au fleuve ce qu'il a ce qu'on
lui a pris aujourd'hui victimes ont à la
fois ce bel ouvrage on a aussi une belle
zone de biodiversité
au total 14 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour ce projet plusieurs
participations de l'état du conseil
départemental de la région à travers des
fonds européens ou encore de la
communauté d'agglomération saint germain
boucle dustin la compétence de lutte
contre les risques d'inondation est
devenue intercommunale est donc en a mis
en place un système un plan de
financement avec la de la région du
département de l'état de l' agence de
l'eau des villes et de l'interco pour
arriver enfin à lancer cette opération
au total ce projet a permis de prolonger
la dic sur 780 mètres avec une hauteur
d'un mètre 20 par rapport au niveau de
la route en prenant comme référence la
crue de 1955
[Musique]
et ce lundi 15 novembre c'est la journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés est empêché pour l'occasion
une table ronde est organisée sur ce
thème à la commanderie ça se passera ce
soir donc à 20h30 et pour parler de ce
sujet avec nous catherine baron
responsable donc de la commanderie
écritures contemporaines donc de saint
quentin en yvelines bonsoir et on a
également anderson dea michel
journaliste haïtien réfugiés bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous bonsoir c'est un
plaisir de tous alors avec plaisir
également vous participez donc tous les
deux à cette rencontre ce soir je me
tourne d'abord vers vous catherine baron
c'est la onzième édition donc de cette
soirée pourquoi c'est important de
marquer justement cette journée de se
retrouver pour parler de ce sujet ce que
c'est une manière de sensibiliser
alors effectivement c'est une manière de
parler de la liberté d'expression
à travers cette journée mondiale de
l'écrivain en prison déclaré par le pn
international et autour de cette journée
en fait on invite depuis 11 ans à saint
quentin en yvelines trois auteurs qui
ont connu la persécution du fait de
leurs écrits et on rencontre des
collégiens des lycéens là depuis lui
novembre on a rencontré plus de 400
élèves
pour témoigner pour parler de parcours
atypique et surtout de voix lasse de
kiné qui n'ont pas eu droit à la parole
et qui ont dû quitter leur pays et qui
ont été accueillis par la france par la
maison des journalistes et l'atelier des
artistes en exil qui sont nos
partenaires et donc vous du coup
anderson dea michel vous êtes
intervenants ce soir on lisait de par
votre vécu et votre témoignage est ce
que justement nous parler un peu de
votre histoire personnelle vous faites
du géant malice tahitien donc j'ai
commencé dans bâle médias en 2014 donc
au début j'ai traité des sujets liés la
culture nées en 2000 17 octobre j'ai
commencé à traiter des sujets en fait
j'avais mon propre émission c'était
haïti c'est soit de dijon public où je
traiter des sujets assez sensible et des
sujets liés à la corruption liées aux
massacres qu'il ya eu pendant plusieurs
fois en haïti parce qu'on a connus de
2018 à 2021 environ 5 massacres et des
journalistes ont été tués donc des
civils des innocents comme ça par des
gangs armés qui ont été en fait qui ont
été fédérer aujourd'hui ce solde du
pouvoir exécutif donc raison de lait des
sujets que j'avais traité dans mon
émission j'ai été victime de plusieurs
tentatives d'assassinât
du coup j'ai dû quitter en juin 2019
pour rentrer en france pour demander
l'asile donc aujourd'hui je suis
résident à la maison des journalistes
une structure qui accueille des
journalistes exilés ça existe depuis
2002 la maison des journalistes a déjà
acquis environ 400 journalistes et qui
viennent dans 70 pays déjà qui est la
maison des journalistes dans une une
chambre c'est journaliste exilé il ya
quatorze chambres à la maison des
journalistes et la maison des
journalistes les accompagne aussi dans
leurs démarches administratives jusqu'à
l'obtention de leur statut de réfugié
politique est aussi le leur aide à
trouver un logement donc pour des
journalistes qui sont pas francophones
la maison des journalistes offre aussi
des cours de français mais des coups de
français la disposition de ses
journalistes exilés donc voilà
aujourd'hui je travaille pour le média
qui s'appelle geeti news qui est un
média franco exilés où on travaille en
binôme on traite en fait on pour un
double rudaz sur l'actualité donc voilà
c'est en gros c'est un peu ça et
pourquoi avoir justement accepté de
participer cette table-ronde donc pour
témoigner en fait c'est pour moi c'est
toujours important de faire savoir qu'il
ya certains pays où la liberté de la
presse est vraiment menacée ou tout
simplement la liberté de la presse
n'existe pas c'est important que la
communauté internationale pour moi
aujourd'hui des sages qui se passe
aujourd'hui en haïti de savoir qu'il ya
des politiques qui font beaucoup de
pression et sur la presse et sur la
population donc c'est important pour moi
parce qu'à chaque fois que je parle avec
des étrangers ils m'ont dit tout le
temps mais je connaissais pas et est de
ce côté là c'est koné s'est jamais cette
histoire donc et parce qu'il ya aussi ce
problème lié à l'information et il ya
certains journalistes qui disent pas
vraiment tout ce qui se passe en haïti
qui raconte une partie mais qui par le
passé donc moi je me suis dit c'est
mieux d'en parler c'est mieux de
sensibiliser la communauté
internationale sur la situation actuelle
d'haïti c'est le rôle que vous êtes
donné donc mais oui donc vous avez été
contraints à l'exil vous venez de nous
l'expliquer est ce que ça donne plus
envie finalement de se battre pour cette
liberté d'expression à ce qu'on ferait
ça peut freiner temps donné que
maintenant vous êtes exilé ici en fait
aujourd'hui j'ai plus de liberté pour
traiter des sujets liés à la situation
politique de mon pays la situation
sociale déjà je le dis tout le temps et
en tissant pays en crise c'est un pays
où aujourd'hui rien ne fonctionne et les
gangs contrôle puisque tout l'été outre
aux haïtiens donc moi c'est vraiment
important de continuer à en parler à
travers la rédaction aujourd'hui je
travaille comme journaliste rédacteur
avant j'étais présentateur à la radio
donc je me suis dit c'est important de
continuer à en parler mais je je je sens
cette liberté en france de pouvoir
m'exprimer sans censure sans de pression
bien que ma famille est temps qu on ait
ihya il ya toujours des conséquences
parce que j'avais traité un sujet en
février et ça a eu des répercussions
directes sur ma famille et elle a été
attaquée en février 2021 donc mais pour
moi directement j'ai pas subi de
ménager pas été victimes en france mais
à chaque fois que j'essaie de travailler
de traiter des sujets liés à la
corruption c'est toujours ma famille
parce que l en haïti n'ont pas pu vous
suivre malheureusement vous allez quand
même des nouvelles oui on parle mais on
parle pas souvent on parle quand même je
vous propose de découvrir un autre
témoignage aussi d'une personne qui
était dans votre cas ça y est tu étais
journaliste il a été menacé de mort à
kaboul en afghanistan il a dû suivre
suire pardon son pays il est désormais
réfugié il travaille à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines sega tsongo et
bixente mais rien sont esteban l'ont
rencontré voici son portrait
depuis juin 2021 sayyed travail dans
cette ressourcerie à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ici ils
récupèrent des appareils électriques les
nettoie et les revend une activité bien
loin de son métier d'origine sayyed est
afghan à kaboul il était journaliste
pigiste pour plusieurs télévisions
locales il a aussi travaillé avec la
croix-rouge d'afghanistan était une
forme de commentaire medio publicité
j'ai fait un montage aussi mais quand je
suis allé à notre village pour le faire
a levé duo part au documentaire de tous
les mondes téléphone avec le camra ce
n'était pas possible parce que l'état
les banques cécile est tellement vu ça
autre problème pour moi en décembre 2018
il retourne dans la province de nimroz
dans le sud ouest de l'afghanistan là où
les talibans ils font leur loi il est
alors accusée d'espionnage le début des
problèmes pour sayed d'espions
travailler pour les autres pays donc le
boulot c'est pas vrai alors
caméra
après cette altercation sayed repart à
kaboul mais les menaces de mort continue
il est désormais dans le viseur des
talibans le 10 février 2019 il tente
même de le kidnapper en pleine rue sont
nés trop pour sayed le 12 février ils
quittent l'afghanistan en laissant sa
femme et ses deux enfants je crée
beaucoup de l'argent pour un programme
doivent gaza paxton après iran après top
mais après le torque
plusieurs pieds d'europe après j'arrive
j'avais un mois de mars mars 2010neuf
j'arrive à allemande après elle m'a mis
dans le centre aux gens ce réfugié
on sent que cinq mois après cinq ans il
m'a dit ok tu peux aller retour ou sayed
choisit donc la france un long périple
administratif des buts il dort sous une
tente porte de la chapelle à paris deux
mois plus tard il rejoint le centre
d'hébergement d'urgence de bonnel il
obtient alors le statut de réfugié en
décembre 2020 à 33 ans sayyed attend
maintenant que sa famille obtienne un
visa pour venir en france cachée elle
est toujours menacé de mort à kaboul
on vient de découvrir le témoignage de
sayyed du coup je me tourne vers vous et
anderson est ce que vous vous retrouvez
un peu dans cette histoire à ce qu'elle
fait écho à votre propre histoire
j'imagine qu'il a dû laisser également
sa famille oui moi j'ai toujours dit que
vous faites est exilé cessé d'avoir ce
sentiment d'abandonner une partie de soi
c'est abandonner sa famille ni ses
activités et des choses auxquelles on
tenait beaucoup donc et c'est vraiment
touré commencé c'est recommencer à zéro
tu tu arrives dans une société auquel tu
connais pas vraiment la culture tu
maîtrises pas parfois la langue
certaines choses c'est toujours
difficile c'est toujours difficile à
chaque fois que moi j'entends un
témoignage de dunes personnes exilées je
comprends ce qui en fait ce qu'il
travaille je comprends pas ce que savait
ce que ça veut dire être exilé donc
déjà la maison des journalistes je
rencontre souvent des journalistes
guinée est aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
journalistes afghans au seuil à la
maison des journalistes après la prise
kaboul donc la maison des jeunes à l'iss
à héberger plusieurs journalistes
afghans dans lequel j il y en a avec qui
j'ai discuté donc c'est toujours pas
facile de partager cette histoire là de
partager nos vécus parce qu'on sait
c'est dur y en a en fait à chaque a fait
des expériences assez particulier les
menaces ont été assez différentes par
exemple il y avait un journaliste qui
qui est libanais qui était à la maison
des journalistes qui s'appelle ibrahim
qui a été enlevé et pendant plusieurs
jours il ya d'autres journalistes qui
ont vécu autre chose mais c'est toujours
des histoires assez assez fort assez
touchant donc je me retrouve souvent
donc je suppose dire que c'est pas
facile et je comprends
vraiment bien quand journalistes exilés
raconte son histoire en tout cas d'avoir
raconté la botte parce que c'est
important de s'en rendre compte
justement ici en france serait qu'on a
de la chance mais mais c'est important
de s'en rendre compte je me tourne vers
vous pour une dernière petite question
brillamment parce que cette semaine a
été également ponctué et sera peut-être
encore ponctuée de rencontres avec les
établissements scolaires c'est important
justement de leur transmettre à ces
jeunes générations des les sensibiliser
aussi sur ce sujet là oui complètement
alors maintenant depuis
les malheureux attentats
les jeunes sont un peu plus la réalise
davantage que la liberté d'expression
c'est fragile
mais c'est vrai il ya une telle écoute
et un questionnement et en plus des
exemples avec ces trois auteurs là je
voudrais citer les deux autres personnes
à marie natura qui est donc
vénézuélienne chanteuse colombienne
activistes qui est arrivé en france il
ya trois ans en parler le français des
vrais et
des vrais nine qui est boîte kurde qui
est arrivé depuis un an qui ne parlait
pas un mot de français là ils sont venus
témoigner en français c'est aussi une
leçon de courage et recommence comme
disait anderson 3 0 ils apprennent le
français
a mis à marie a décidé de repasser un
diplôme de sage femme
voilà cesser ce sont des exemples pour
les jeunes aussi et pourront merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nos catherine
barons dont vous êtes la responsable à
de commanderies écritures contemporaines
donc de saint quentin en yvelines et
puis anderson dea michel dont vous êtes
journaliste haïtien réfugiés merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
je le rappelle la rencontre aura lieu
donc ce soir l'événement est gratuit ce
serait à la commanderie à d'elancourt à
20h30 et la ronde sera animée donc on
disait par nouradine à une journaliste
pour marmite fm
[Musique]
et on passe aux sports à présent c'est
un tout autre sujet le beach tennis fait
son apparition sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines les adeptes de
cette discipline peuvent des âmes
désormais s'affronter sur le sable à
l'espace événementiel une pratique
encadrée par l'association paris ouest
beach tennis le reportage de mélanie
poker et mathilde de franck
les pieds dans le sable et le beach
tennis se pratique en général en duo
mixte ou non mixtes sur un terrain de
beach volley avec un filet à 1 mètre 70
ou 1 m 82 auteur rapporte hisse donc
effectivement on est sur le sol donc là
pas de rebond possible on joue avec des
balles qui ressemble à bâle de mini
tennis et on a dit raquette voilà en
carbone fibre de verre qui frapperait
350 g c'est très physique où est sûre
long terme c'est quand même physique en
et sur le sable de déplacement et quand
même particulier ce qui est génial c'est
qu'on arrive aussi à des plongeons quand
on est en difficulté
l'association paris ouest beach tennis
existe depuis février 2021 et compte
aujourd'hui une trentaine de licenciés
les membres de l'association cherchait
un lieu plus grand et à proximité pour
pratiquer ce sport c'est dur de trouver
des terrains aujourd'hui on a un seul
terran qui est située sur meudon donc du
côté de deux sèvres et on le partage
avec le beach volley donc aujourd'hui on
est trente adhérents partagent avec le
beach volley autant dire que les chronos
sont très difficiles à trouver et ce qui
est vraiment frustrant c'est qu'on peut
pas jouer tous ensemble comme
aujourd'hui les terrains de beach tennis
n'étant pas encore aux normes ces
derniers seront bientôt agrandi à terme
l'association espère voir la
construction de quatre terrains
homologués pour pouvoir organiser des
tournois et des événements les terrains
là vous été mis à disposition
au travers d'une convention d'occupation
avec une transformation qui arrivera
sous peu puisque pour que les terrains
soient aux normes ils ont besoin d'être
légèrement agrandie par rapport à la
taille qu'ils ont la taille existantes
le beach tennis peut se pratiquer tout
au long de l'année été comme hiver
l'adhésion est de 60 euros pour l'année
et la licence pour la fédération
française de tennis est à 30 euros
culture lucarne au sort d'une école de
cinéma le jeune réalisateur riches
bourgeois et hémiplégique suite à un
accident vasculaire cérébral à la
naissance il s'ouvre maintenant de
paralysie et d'un côté du corps il a
réalisé un court métrage très personnel
où il raconte son handicap et le
dépassement de soi à travers son
personnage
maxime un fils qui a été tourné dans les
yvelines donc un riche bourg céline
charles est allé sur place regarder
antoine 21 ans est hémiplégique veut
s'inscrire à une course de 10 km contre
l'avis de son médecin de l'organisateur
et de sa famille c'est le héros du court
métrage second souffre de lucas renault
qui a nécessité six jours de tournage
une équipe de 40 personnes et 50
figurants du court métrage parle de du
combat contre la considération des
autres qui est souvent mauvais sens
faite par rapport un regard que nous
avons sur nous mêmes et donc de
l'émancipation en fait de ce regard là
surtout que le regard des autres c'est
ce qui nous construit et donc en fait
vivre avec
un regard négatif sur nous' a forcément
un impact sur notre propre conception de
ce que nous sommes aidés par la
fondation mallet la ccpa chez le
producteur jean marc auclair ce court
métrage qui fait écho à une histoire
personnelle porte un véritable message
d'espoir c'est son bras gauche bah non
maga tu veux qu'ils se fassent pas
pourquoi ça va il n'est pas paralysé non
plus mais ça va je peux le faire
mon chéri tu es né avec ton handicap
c'est normal que tu te rendent plus
compte ce personnage me ressemble au
point nous avons les mêmes difficultés
physiques donc elite hémiplégique que
tout comme moi nous avons eu également
un avc à la naissance cet avc m'a
justement construit et que ça fait ce
que ce que je suis aujourd'hui et quand
même si si j'ai souvent pensé que
c'était un fardeau que c'était vraiment
très compliqué et c'est moi je me dis
que je suis content d'avoir eu cette
expérience entre guillemets au début de
ma vie parce que je suis sûr que ça ne
me servait en fait tout au long mais si
cette course que je fais
je l'avais scellé il est derrière moi
depuis longtemps j'ai juste besoin
d'avancer un peu
j'en ai marre qu'on met des barrières
tout le temps
je vais y arriver des images tournées à
richebourg en yvelines les paysages de
son enfance ses des lieux forcément que
je que je connais depuis mon enfance
parce que je vis à richebourg depuis
depuis maintenant 20 ans donc forcément
c'est des lieux que je connais par coeur
j'ai l'habitude de venir courir ici
pratiquement tous les jours un court
métrage qui doit maintenant se faire une
place il a deux ans pour se faire un nom
dans les festivals avant d'enfin pouvoir
être diffusés au grand public
un reportage avec la voix de bixente mes
liens sont tissés ban et c'est la fin de
ce journal à merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi dans un instant retrouver grégory
canal et à la présentation de votre
magazine sportif très bonne soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]